as most of you know the tech world has
been a little bit slow for the past few
weeks
but apple is about to shake things up
and they're going to go
all out this year with some new products
coming next month
so in this video i'm going to talk about
the products that apple is most likely
to reveal
i'm gonna dig deep into the specs and
prices of each product
and i'm gonna discuss everything else
that we should expect
from apple next month first off we just
got our very first rumor of there being
an apple event
on march 16th according to the economic
daily news
now even though this date is a bit
sooner than the usual
late march apple event dates we did have
an apple event on march 9th
in 2015 and apple did reveal their 2020
ipad pro
on the 18th last year so there is a very
real possibility
that we could be seeing an event on
march 16th next month
however mark german a very reliable
leaker
tweeted that there will be no apple
event on march 16th
he even said in a separate tweet that
quote
there won't end up being one so i don't
know if that means that there's no march
event at all
or if it'll be on another date in march
but one little piece of evidence
pointing to
no march event is that late last week
apple released a huge amount of apple tv
plus content
including some new previews and trailers
i honestly thought that this stuff would
have been shown off at a march event
so what if apple decided to scrap the
entire event at the last minute
and decided to just release this apple
tv plus content online so i'm not really
sure if there's gonna be an event or not
but i do know that they will 100 release
a bunch of products
which i'm about to talk about in this
video even without an event
which is what they did last year so with
that let's get into which products to
expect from apple next month
starting with something they revealed at
their 2019 march event
apple arcade which has been slowly
growing over the past couple of years
but it hasn't really taken off like
apple hoped it would and last year in
june
apple apparently canceled some arcade
games because it just wasn't working out
like they thought it would
but just a couple of months back in
october apple was reported to be
investing
massively into new more engaging games
and as you all know those types of games
take a lot of time to make
so in my personal opinion if there will
be an apple event next month
i think apple is preparing some awesome
new apple arcade game trailers
to be revealed at the event next month
and since they're going to be focusing
on
apple tv software i think it's also the
perfect time
for new apple tv hardware which has been
rumored
for months now so let's get into those
leaks
last year in august bloomberg reported
that a new apple tv
is in the works with an upgraded remote
and that in october
the tweeter leaker fudge claimed that an
a14x
performance simulating apple tv was sent
out to apple arcade developers some time
ago
fudge also said that two new apple tv
models are in the works
for release in 2021 and then in december
nikkei also reported that apple is
working on a new apple tv
for a 2021 release and then just a few
days later
mark german from bloomberg said the
exact same thing
except this time he called it a gaming
focused apple tv
with an updated remote and he also said
that there's going to be a much
stronger gaming focus which would be
perfect if apple were to release
some new high-end apple arcade games
this makes a lot of sense because we've
been seeing reports of a brand new
gaming controller coming
ever since left to dream mentioned it
last year in april
which will support the apple tv and
basically every other apple device
fudge also claimed that a new gaming
controller was coming and we've
continued to see reports of that over
the past few months
so basically i'm expecting a new apple
tv
with an a14x chip which is gonna have
crazy good performance
but i'm also expecting a replacement for
the regular apple tv hd
since there are two models that are
rumored and to make it even more
interesting
there were reports back in 2018 that
apple would be releasing a low-cost
apple tv dongle which would be meant for
those who just want to watch tv content
and this would totally make sense if
apple has a gaming focused high-end
apple tv for those who want to do some
gaming as well
the only problem is that we did recently
get a report saying that the new apple
tv
isn't coming until the end of the year
but i personally don't think that's
gonna happen
because we've been seeing so many leaks
and rumors recently
pointing to a release date much sooner
than that and now
with all of that apple tv stuff out of
the way let's move into the absolute
start of the show
and that's going to be the release of
the brand new 2021 ipad pro
we've been seeing rumors about a new
ipad pro for almost a full year
when ming chico said that apple was
working on a mini led
ipad pro and of course because of the
pandemic we saw many reports saying that
it's going to be delayed until
2021 and quo once again confirmed
that we will in fact be getting a mini
led display
and then et news took it even further
saying that it's going to launch in the
first quarter of 2021
and the same rumor came from digi times
as well
which would mean that the new ipad pro
would have to be released
before the end of march so i'm basically
100
sure that it's going to be released at
apple's march event if they have it
or if not then it's going to be an
online launch my only concern
is that the 11 inch model is going to
get discontinued but both fudge
and love to dream on twitter pointing to
there still being
two models and recently leaked cad
images were leaked
with both 11 inch and 12.9 inch sizes so
that seems much more likely to have both
one thing i am confident about is the
specs
it's going to get a mini led display and
it'll also come with the a14x chip
which is going to be extremely similar
to apple's m1 mac chip
except that it's not going to have all
of the other mac specific hardware
all i know is that it's going to be
extremely powerful
and it most likely is not going to come
with the new design since it just
recently got redesigned
and it seems like apple wants to stick
with the same modern flat side design
for a while
and i personally think that the price
tag is going to be staying basically the
same
eight hundred dollars for the 11 inch if
it does come out and a thousand dollars
for the 12.9 inch
so i'm personally very excited to see
what apple has in store for the next
ipad
pro but we are also expecting one more
ipad
next month and that's the ipad mini i'm
almost 100
sure that it's coming because it's the
only ipad that hasn't been updated
and basically two full years every other
ipad was updated last year
so we should be seeing a new ipad mini
next month
and we have some leaks and rumors to
support that way back in may of 2020
ming chi quo said that we should be
expecting two new ipads
a 10.8 inch ipad in the second half of
2020
and an 8.5 to 9 inch ipad mini
in the first half of 2021. that 10.8
inch ipad turned out to be the ipad air
4
which received a full redesign with the
new rounded corner display
flat sides and back finally a usb c port
and a new touch id power button but we
still haven't seen the mini
so i think it's gonna come next month
because even digitimes said we should be
expecting it to come
alongside the new mini led ipad pro
in the first half of 2021. the main
takeaway is the display size
which should be at least eight inches
potentially up to nine inches
which means that it's almost certainly
getting a full redesign
with a rounded corner display just like
the ipad air 4. we should also be
expecting it to get the same flat sides
and back
as well as the same exact touch id power
button
but while the air gets a usb-c port some
rumors are pointing to it actually
sticking with lightning
which is really weird but it might make
sense since the budget ipad is still
using
lightning i also expected to get the
same a14 bionic chip as the ipad air has
and i kind of doubt that apple will be
giving it the mini led display right
away
but i guess we're just gonna have to
wait and see and i think the price tag
will be somewhere between
400 and 500 since they bumped up the
ipad air's price
by a hundred dollars compared to the
previous model
so that's basically it for the ipads and
now
we just have one final product that we
should be expecting
and that's the apple air tags these
things have been rumored for a
very very long time and john prosser
even showed us some renders of the air
tag and apparently
love to dream on twitter says that we
should be getting
two different sizes of air tags and just
last week
we got some more rumors from john
prosser
saying that the air tags are scheduled
to launch in march
alongside the new ipad pro so i'm pretty
confident that they're coming
apart from that we are expecting some
new airpods
both the airpods 3 and the pro 2s but
i'm really not sure if they're going to
be coming
next month or in april i personally
think that they're going to be coming in
april because they are launching
so many things in march already but i
guess we're just gonna have to wait and
see so there you guys go
that's everything that you should be
expecting from apple's march event next
month
or potentially just an online launch
like they did last year
so if you enjoyed this video go ahead
and tap the like button and click the
circle about to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in
the next video
you